-Ana Gasteyer, Rachel Dratch!
-Yes!
-Hi!
-Hello. Jimmy.
-You guys look fantastic.
It's great to see you.
I missed you.
-We missed you too.
-We missed you too, Jimmy!
-"Jimmy, we miss you, Jimmy!"
Can you believe we've
known each other 20 years?
-Oh, my God.
-So long.
-Does that make any sense?
-Yeah, well, more than that,
because Frances is 19,
and she was born
when I left "Saturday Night."
So we've known each other for --
-Over 20 years.
-Maybe 24.
-Oh, my Lord.
-How are the kids?
-Everybody's good.
-They're great.
Everyone's great.
-Yeah.
-Do they watch you?
I mean, they're at the age
they know your work now.
-So, Frances is over it,
because she's in college.
She's just
officially embarrassed.
-She's in college?
-Yeah, she's in college.
My 13-year-old loves
"Schweddy Balls," obviously.
-As we all do. Yeah, of course.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, not because of that.
-It's an American classic.
-Not because of that,
but because of the content.
But then, so, we were watching
a Christmas show the other day,
because it came on.
You know, the Christmas special
they do on "SNL" thing.
And I was actually --
We were in a hotel.
We were down for Thanksgiving.
And "Topless Christmas" came on,
and that was
"Martha Stewart's Topless..."
-"Martha Stewart's
Topless Christmas."
-And you played Martha Stewart.
-Yeah, and that was
actually the first time
that he was ashamed.
[ Laughter ]
He turned, like,
the most amazing color of red,
and he doesn't
blush easily, so....
-That was such a good bit.
Ana, you have a new show on NBC.
-I do.
-Debuting on Monday.
-Is it on Monday?
-December 13th.
-Monday...
-Yeah. Monday-ish.
-...December 13th, yeah.
-What a long pause.
It's on Monday. Is it?
-It's Monday after this Monday.
-Yeah, not this Monday.
-Yeah.
-Monday, December 13th.
-December 13th.
-Yeah, that's correct.
That's when it comes out.
-It's after "The Voice."
-"American Auto."
-Blake Shelton's "The Voice."
-It's after "The Voice."
-Yeah.
-That's a good lead-in.
-They're doing a sneak peek
of the first two episodes,
and then it starts airing
for real in January.
And it's set --
It's Justin Spitzer,
who created "Superstore."
It's his new show.
It's an office comedy.
NBC, you know -- they love a
half-hour office-oriented
comedy, workplace comedy.
And it's set in
the automotive industry,
and I play the new female C.E.O.
I come from Big Pharma.
I've got questionable morals.
And I don't know
anything about cars.
-Perfect place to work then.
Yeah, why not?
-So, that's it.
That's in a nutshell.
It's really fun.
It's a great show.
I'm excited about it.
-And then let's talk
about "Clusterfunke Christmas."
-Yeah.
-By the way, already,
I was laughing at the trailer.
And then I go, "Oh, my God.
I got to watch this."
I love Hallmark movies.
I love Lifetime movies.
I'm honest. I love them.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I absolutely love them. Right?
-They're the best.
-I think they --
I don't know what it is.
I just love it.
I go, "Oh, my gosh,
why has no one spoofed this?"
And you crushed it.
-And that's what we've done.
-Now, where did you -- Yeah.
-So, Jimmy, let me tell you.
This is a parody of a
Hallmark/Lifetime
Christmas movie.
And we just wanted to do --
You know, like you said,
we thought this was an area
that's ripe for parody.
-Mm-hmm.
We enjoy an
"Airplane!"-style spoof.
-Yeah, sort of our model
was the movie "Airplane!",
if you applied that to --
-And we couldn't believe
no one had done it.
And, like you,
we've watched thousands of them,
and they all pretty much
have the same plot.
So it seemed pretty easy to,
you know --
-Right. So we picked the plot
that we've seen the most,
which is like,
you know, big-time --
like, executive woman
in the big city
who has no time
for love or Christmas
gets sent by her business
to a small town,
where she meets a, like, insert
small-town profession here.
-Craftsperson, a craftsman.
-Lumberjack, toy-maker,
what have you.
-Yeah, sleigh-maker.
-And then, at first --
And she's just there
to take over a quaint business.
And, at first,
they don't get along.
They butt heads.
But then, guess what.
I wonder if she's going to find
love and
the spirit of Christmas.
-She might find
-We don't want to
ruin the ending.
-We don't want to ruin it,
but it does happen.
-It does.
-Yeah.
-That's the best way
anyone's ever summed up
any project that they've come on
the show to talk about.
-There's also a stray dog.
We threw in everything
that you've ever seen.
-Every trope we could think of
we tried to throw in.
-Meaningful snowfall.
It starts snowing when there's
a big, emotional moment.
-Lot of cocoa.
-Lots of hot chocolate.
-A questionably gay
platonic friend.
-Yeah.
-We threw in whatever
we could throw in there.
-It's all in there.
It's all there.
-And we, naturally,
play the spinsters,
the old spinsters
who run the inn.
-So, when we were talking about
what we might do in this movie,
there was just --
there wasn't even a discussion.
Like, one of us just said like,
"And we're going to play
the old spinsters
that run the inn, right?"
It was like, "Yeah, of course."
Because it's like we wanted to
put on the gray buns --
-We got our Party City buns.
-Yeah, Party City hairdos.
-Because the thing is,
in these worlds,
in the Hallmark and Lifetime
world, as you know,
you're either an ingenue
and you're eligible for breeding
or you're Mrs. Claus.
There is really no...
-You know what I like,
is the songs,
the actual holiday songs,
the Christmas songs in this.
-Well, so, you're -- If you are
a student of these films,
they're all made for $15
in Vancouver in July, okay?
-That's where we shot it.
-And that's where we shot it.
That's where we shot it.
And there's Christmas
in every frame.
And it's like a machine
that just, like,
churns out these
amazing holiday parodies.
-And there's product placement.
-Product placement.
We have that throughout.
Lots of product placement.
-But you can't do real --
Like, there's a lot of movies
that they want to start with
"Jingle Bell Rock,"
but they can't
afford the rights,
so there's -- It sort of sounds
like "Jingle Bell Rock."
So we wrote some songs
like that, "Jangle Ball Shake."
-Yeah, "Jangle Bell Shake."
-And instead of "All I Want
for Christmas is You"...
-By Mariah Carey.
-...it's "All I Have for
Christmas is Fruit"
by Shaniah Gary.
-Ooh!
-It's close.
People overeat
around that time of the year,
so it has a nice message.
-It's just in
the background, though.
That's not a theme in the movie.
-Yes, it's great.
Anyways, I want to show
everyone a clip here.
This is Ana Gasteyer
and Rachel Dratch in
"A Clusterfunke Christmas."
Take a look at this.
-What I'm trying to say is,
I'm not just here
for the upcoming Bonfire Fest,
as lovely as it seems.
-Let me guess.
You came to get away from
the breakneck pace of your life
as an executive in the city.
-No. I am --
-Got fired?
-No.
-Widowed?
-Runaway bride?
-No.
-You inherited a bookstore
here in town?
-No.
-You're a single mom
whose husband ditched out
on the family, and now
you're here to meet up with
a single dad whose wife
ditched out on his family
so you can blend both families
together by Christmas?
-You came to run a
Christmas children's chorus
and find your own voice
in the process?
-You have amnesia,
wandered into town by accident,
and won't remember your identity
until Christmas morning?
-Your boyfriend is
here for the winter,
but he's secretly a prince of
a small Slavic nation.
-You're here to track down
the owner of a locket you found
hidden away
in a Christmas ornament.
-That's locked inside
a music box.
-That's been hidden away
in your attic for 40 years?
-No.
-Oh.
-That is how you do it.
That is exactly
how you do it right there.
Ana Gasteyer, Rachel Dratch.